So now, let's look at how do
we form the offset index and
tag in the address for
set-associative caches?
This is a two way set-associative
cache that has four sets.
When the processor produces an address,
the least significant bits
that tell us where in the block we are,
are still determined by the block size.
The indexed bits are the ones that tell
us which set are we talking about.
So the number of index bits is
determined by how many sets we have.
In this case, we have four sets,
so we need two index bits.
The remaining bits are the tag.
Like in a direct mapped cache,
once we have placed the line in for
example set zero,
we know that everything that maps to set
zero will have bits zero zero here, so
we don't have to keep that in the tag.
In set zero, we only need to
make sure that what we now need,
matches what we have in the uppermost
bits, not in the indexed bits.
Because the fact that we're looking at
set zero, means that we have already
determined that these bits are zero
zero, and everything that we could have
placed here,
also has zero zero bits in the index.
Interestingly, a direct-mapped
cache of the same size
will have one more index bit, so
it would have slightly smaller tag.